i'm going to teach you the entrepreneur
success formula this is the formula it's
very simple it's easy to apply that when
you actually execute it it will change
the course of your life and your
business the entrepreneur success
formula
are you ready
you need to if you want to have success
as an entrepreneur combine what you love
doing with what brings value to other
people
people mess us up what you love doing
with what brings value to other people
in that intersection is your next great
genius amazing business idea here's what
most people do
most people just pick one
most people either pick what they love
doing
but they can't figure out how to bring
value to other people so you've got a
hobby if you love doing something it
just fills you up it's amazing but it
never brings value to other people then
you never get paid you've got a really
fulfilling hobby and that can be great
and your hobby can be something you do
in the evenings and weekends and it
fills up your soul
but you'll never turn that into a
business if you don't figure out how to
bring value to other people so you're
stuck always having to have a job or go
work for somebody else
while you're doing your hobby on the on
the weekends evenings on the side etc so
those are the people who just chase what
they love doing right chase your passion
amazing
there's other people a lot of
entrepreneurs who
just go after the money
just try to bring value just go after
opportunity right that's the only focus
like i'll do whatever it takes i need to
be a millionaire by the time i'm x years
old
i'll do whatever it takes but you won't
you will not do whatever it takes
because as soon as it gets hard you're
going to lose and the problem is you're
going up against people who love it pick
whatever industry you open up a
magazine or website it shows you the
hottest businesses for next year these
are the industries that will take off
and you have to get into it it's like oh
wow that's hot i'm going to go off and
do those things if you don't absolutely
love it right this part here if you
don't actually love it what you love
doing with it brings value to other
people if you don't absolutely love it
you're going to lose because you're
going up against people who do love it
if it's just a strategy for you
but for other people they love it you're
going to lose every time you can lose
every time because
while you're counting the hours and
while you're trying to figure oh my gosh
when is this going to pay off you're
going up against people who aren't even
tracking it who get lost in it who 12
hours later they're still doing the
thing because they love it so much and
they can't believe that where is the
time gone
so it has to be in that combination so
many entrepreneurs start a business
because they're thinking to make a lot
of money and they end up going broke and
it wasn't because the idea was bad the
idea could have been fantastic the
problem was you didn't love it enough
you didn't care about it enough it was
just a strategy it's just an opportunity
for you instead of being actually
something that you love so the
entrepreneur success formula
you start with doing what you love
and then you figure out how to bring
value to other people doing it
me motivation what to top 10 with
believe nation
hey it's nina carmichael and we made
these videos it's because you're
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you need a push but surround
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best my husband
evan carmichael and our take on his top
10 rules for success enjoy
rule number two have a good morning
routine staying consistent on your
morning routine
is the difference between you having
a good life and a great life the life
that you're living right now which is
good listen you have a good life right
now if you're watching this you have
internet you have food you know you have
a place to sleep tonight you have you
have a pretty good life
you have a pretty good life but it's not
a great life
you know you know you're capable of more
you know you want to do more you know
that where you are right now is not
where you want to be that imagine a year
two years five years imagine if you were
still in the same spot in five years
imagine your life your health your
relationships your finances the impact
you're having your
your routine your daily like what you're
doing on a regular
and nothing has changed in five years
it'd still be a good life but it's not a
great life
right it's not a great life
this is the struggle that you know
you're capable of so much more if you
didn't know you're capable of more
ignorance is bliss
you just keep living your life
but when you know you're capable of more
this is the the curse of the achievers
like you know you're capable of so much
more no matter how much people look at
you and say hey wow you're doing so well
you're doing so much
that that's why you're watching these
videos you are the most ambitious person
that you know people look to you for
guidance and wisdom advice and support
and encouragement and hope and
inspiration like you're the one filling
other people up you're the one inspiring
other people to do better to be more to
go after their dreams that's you but
who's doing that for you
you know you're capable of so much more
and so how do you get it how do you how
do you do the work well it's a daily
thing this is
this is part of the challenges it's a
daily thing it gets boring
it gets boring
do the exact same thing every day
to stay consistent on what you said you
were gonna do
and we start to doubt ourselves
you have days where you're motivated
inspired ready to take on the world
feeling amazing and other days where you
don't feel so good and you think wake up
feeling like who am i i can't do this
what i said i was gonna do that you look
at your goals like i'm gonna i'm gonna
do that there's no way i'm gonna do that
me
i'm gonna stay in bed
it's the thing achievers don't talk
about is there's a lot of days when you
just don't feel like you're worthy of it
you don't believe in yourself you don't
think that you can do it
and it's just that consistency that
prevents you from doing the thing
because you'll have the days when you're
on fire and then entire days maybe weeks
sometimes but you're just not doing
anything
and so how do you how do you keep that
momentum how do you keep that
consistency it starts with the morning
routine
and the goal of the morning routine
is to help you feel
motivated bold courageous ready to take
on the day
that's what the goal of the morning
routine is
everybody's got a morning routine if
you're watching this you've got a
mortgage everybody doesn't have a
morning routine most people actually
wake up like an accident right most
people wake up
and they fall into their day and they
look at their phone and it's other
people's emergencies and other people's
demands for your time that's most
people's day but for you if you're
watching this
you're you're an achiever
and you have some kind of morning
routine
but most people's morning routine
are also broken because you're not doing
it consistently enough or you're not
doing it with enough intent
so if you ask what's the goal of a
morning routine
the goal of morning routine is to get
you bold and prepped and ready for the
day let me ask you this if you were to
for the next year of your life right 365
days the next year of your life you're
going to wake up
and do something that would make you
feel bold powerful courageous motivated
not asking you to wake up feeling bold
powerful courageous motivated but to
wake up tired however you wake up
i woke up tired today
you wake up
and then you do something that will help
you feel bold powerful motivated
courageous and ready to take on the day
if you woke up and did that for the next
how much does your life change how much
does the next year change how much does
the does the impact that you're making
does the actual momentum that you're
taking towards your goals how much does
that change
if in the next year you actually did
that
it should be tremendously it should be
dramatically because no matter how much
you're doing your morning routine
one you're probably not super consistent
on it and two you're not getting the
feeling even if you are
that's what needs to change rule number
three tell your story your story is your
competitive advantage
why you do what you do where you came
from your history all of the the baggage
the imperfections the vulnerability all
of that your story
is the thing that's going to help you
win as an entrepreneur this is one of
the biggest misconceptions and one of
the hardest things for us to do as
entrepreneurs to put ourselves out there
and share the story
we want to be perfect we see these big
brands we see people popping off on
instagram and their perfect life and
their perfect planes and their perfect
marketing
and we feel not good enough and we feel
like we have to be like them but people
can smell through it
think about it you're going up against
some big company right whatever industry
you're in there's some big players more
establishing you bigger budgets than you
deeper pockets than you they've been
there forever they've got the brand name
the history their reputation people know
who they are and you're going up against
them
why would somebody buy from you
instead of them
because of your story
because you're going to make me feel
special because in you i see myself i
see somebody who cares i see somebody
who's going to go off and make a
difference where i have no connection to
big company to big corporation but what
most entrepreneurs do is they try to
look the part of being the big corporate
they have a really formal website they
have a really formal
photography they have a really formal
bio
at best you're going to be a junior
junior junior junior version of that big
company
i need to know why you do what you do
this is how you win your heart is your
competitive advantage
why do you care so much
and if you believe like i believe that
your purpose comes from your pain that
whatever you're doing right now your
deep purpose is to help other people who
currently are who you used to be then i
need to know what pain you've come
through
because you might have the answers you
might have the solution your product
your service your coaching your content
whatever could actually be the solution
but until i know
that you've come through the thing that
i'm struggling with i'm not going to
listen to you because i'm going to think
yeah right this person doesn't get it
this person doesn't understand me this
person doesn't care
meanwhile you do care meanwhile it's the
most important thing meanwhile you care
way more than anybody else cares but
until you actually share your story
nobody's gonna listen
this is one of the hardest things for me
to overcome when i started my business
because i always felt well nobody cares
about my story like who cares it's not
about me i i have no need to be in front
of a camera i'm i'm introverted and shy
by nature i know you may not believe
that watching these videos but i am
and
like i remember fighting with my agent
steve
many times i will not steve nobody cares
about what i've done and my story and i
don't i don't like the spotlight on me
so why does it matter and after years of
fighting and hopefully what took me
forever to figure out
if you guys get this in this video
you'll be way further ahead than i was
when i was getting started
people learn through your story and if
you've got a message
you telling your story actually
perpetuates the message so you telling
your story is not about you and your ego
and how you look and how people see you
and prizes and awards and anything it's
about making an impact because when i
know that you've been through
what i'm going through or i know how
much you care about something i'm much
more likely to want to hire you so let
me give you a couple examples
i remember i was doing a radio show and
when i first got started
uh in in coaching it was through a live
radio show that i was doing once a week
i remember one person calling in and he
had a landscaping business
and i asked okay well what's so
different about your landscaping company
because he was frustrated that all of
these teenagers and high school kids
were eating up his business where say
hey we'll landscape your yard and we'll
do it for minimum wage and here he is
trying to make more than minimum wage
and he's worried that he has to compete
on price and he can't do it against
these teenagers and so i said well why
do you why do you care so much about
landscaping man like why did you pick
this business and i hope for all of you
please that you have a story right if
you're picking a business just to make
money you've lost already
you've lost that the entrepreneurial
success formula is you got to combine
what you love doing with what brings
value to other people you have to love
it you have to have a story if there's
no story you've lost go pick something
else that you actually can't connect to
but i asked why did you start this
business what does it mean to you and he
said
my mom was my hero
and when i was young
she always took me out to the yard and
we did landscaping together
and it's always a connection to her
and then there was a line that he said
they really caught me where he said
every
lawn that i go to every customer's loan
that i go help
i treat it like it's my mom's lawn
and right there it's like oh my gosh
this guy cares so much like do you think
the average high school
after school summer job do you think
they care as much about your yard as
this guy does
right if he's treating it like it's his
mom's garden
and by sharing that story now you'd be
willing to pay more i'd be willing to
pay him way more than a high school kid
because i think that he's going to give
a way better service provide way more
value because i understand the story
rule number four have an infinite
mindset having an infinite mindset comes
from you wanting people to win more than
you want them to win with you
you want people to win around you your
friends your family your team your
customers the people you interact with
you want them to win as people in their
life in their goals whatever they want
to accomplish you want them to win
more
than you want them to win with you
if you can start to adopt that mindset
it really starts to shift how you see
your relationships how you see your
business how do you see the people on
your team and it allows so much more
positive energy to flow in the right
direction for everybody to accomplish
their goals so quick example
i made a video i made a bunch of videos
on tony robbins tony robbins was one of
the
first people that
he was i guess the first big person who
kind of recognized the work that i was
doing and he put the video i made on him
on his home page on youtube and got a
lot more views and we made more videos
on tony robbins tony then invites me to
go to his event we did a couple
interviews together he invites me to go
and puts me in you know the awesome
seating right up front and i got a lot
of people coming up to say hey evan
they recognize me i'm also wearing a
hoodie
not that i'm a celebrity but in that
kind of world people would recognize me
and they said you introduced me to tony
robbins
that they found out about tony robbins
or simon sinek or tom bilyeu or whoever
through the content that i'm putting up
and i had a few people who said hey i i
found out about tony robbins
from you
and i haven't actually gone back and
watched your videos in a while because
i've been so deep in tony robbins land
and now i'm here at this event and paid
thousands of dollars to be here learning
from tony
and i don't watch your channel anymore
but thank you for introducing me to tony
robbins because that's what i watch now
i'm pumped
i'm excited it's like that's amazing
thank you for telling me
now would i would i love for them to be
with me forever yes of course absolutely
but i'm more happy that you're off
winning if you watch this video and you
learn from simon sinek and you've never
heard of him before you have and you
want to dive deeper and then you go and
you buy all his books and you subscribe
to him on youtube and you dive deep into
his world and you don't come back and
watch another video of mine for another
12 months i'm i'm pumped for you i want
you to win as a human as an entrepreneur
more than i want you to subscribe to my
channel and keep watching videos here
it's just a fundamental shift in how you
see relationships i look at the people
on my team i want them all to win as
people more than win with me and i see
everybody that i'm working with as a
parallel path
you and i right now you're watching this
video we're on a parallel path this is a
parallel path that we're we're marching
on together and then at the end of this
video you're going to go off and go do
something else and hopefully productive
and empowering and impactful you're
gonna have a great day come on let's go
believe nation but you're gonna go off
and do something else you're gonna
you're gonna step out different karmico
path and go do something else and maybe
you come back on the path or maybe you
go way off and you and you never come
back but right now you're watching this
video we're on a parallel path you and i
together
i just want to maximize that time
together that while you're on a path
with me that you're going to become
better and that should be your goal with
the people you're around that we have
these parallel paths that we're running
together
for a certain amount of time and maybe
that's
10 minutes in a conversation maybe
that's a year of somebody working with
you maybe that's 10 years maybe that's a
life partner that's forever right but
you're on these parallel paths your goal
needs to be while somebody's interacting
with you in person
via email through your content they're
with you
that they're a better person because of
that interaction with you
if you can do that if you can just
change the way you see relationships to
do that to instead just think about
yourself first and think about them
first and helping them accomplish what
they need to accomplish even if it means
leaving you
i've i've recommended people to courses
and programs that are not my own i've
kicked people off of my team because
i was going to hold them back they
wanted to stay here but like you need to
go and do that thing this is too safe
and comfortable for you and i can't give
you the thing that you want
you have to leave and go do that thing
and push them towards it also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video i've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five embrace the end embrace
the end most people are thinking or most
people are thinking do i do this or do
with this do i do this business or do
this business if you think about your
passions and your interests right what
do you love doing what's your
heart-centered thing that you could do
all day you probably have a couple
things
and you feel like you have to pick this
is the mistake people feel like you have
to pick you don't have to pick the
actual selection
is in doing both of those things
combined
a lot of people have said some amazing
things of me it's very humbling i think
of edmylet and garyvee where garyvee
called me the dj that likes to watch so
much content and then spin it to inspire
people and ed milette said that i'm the
modern-day napoleon hill napoleon hill
is the biggest influence of all time
personal development and i'm the modern
day napoleon hill first off that's
extremely humbling but
why are they saying that this is how i'm
unique because i love consuming all of
this stuff and i love spinning it and
mixing it up as well as adding my own
message to things this is how i'm
different there's a lot of people who
are just
sharing their message and there's a lot
of people who are also mixing things
together but there's nobody who's really
mixing things together and sharing their
own message right so instead of looking
at those two things as different
right like i have to pick i got to pick
this or this like i'm gonna combine them
and that's how i'm gonna be unique so
think about your different interests
what do you love doing what are what are
your top two three things that you can
get lost in and they feel completely
different
your genius is going to be in actually
mixing those things together in a way
that's never been done before and then
using that to bring value to people
stop thinking or and instead embrace the
end rule number six lean in on your
worry one of the things that really
helped me
was leaning into
the fact that i'm shy and introverted
and
afraid to get in front of the camera and
afraid to get on stage and no need to be
famous
that's led to actually a lot of
opportunities
[Laughter]
the more i lean in on those things the
more things come to me i remember doing
a speech at brendon burchard's growth
event
and
i wasn't as myself i was more
professional i was more just giving
advice great great advice people loved
it and then he invited me back to speak
at his uh private mastermind and now
this these groups are paying 30 to 50
000 to be in that room uh so now there's
a higher pressure you know like the
first one the ticket was maybe 100 bucks
the ticket to this one is thirty
thousand dollars a fifty thousand
dollars like oh my gosh extra pressure
and
i just leaned in on it
i i walked up on stage and i i came
after dean graziosi so dean spoke and
then it was me and dean was using the
flipboard
uh you know this is like a paper beside
you and you're you're flipping one page
at a time and i'd never used a flipboard
in
in any of my presentations i've had
powerpoint in the past where i normally
just get up and talk but i thought okay
i'm going to try to use the flip port
and i didn't know how to use it i i
always felt like i was blocking somebody
uh some hiding behind the flip board
trying to write it and it ended up being
really funny and um
brendan took me aside after
and he said that was the best that was
so much better than you did at in
arizona my first event and arizona was
great but like you need to lean in on
your goofiness you need to lean in on
your shyness you need to lean in on the
things that make you nervous if you're
if you're nervous say you're nervous if
you have anxiety say you have anxiety um
i i'd led with something like that it's
like i'm i'm scared i'm an introvert i'm
shy and i've got my heart beating like
crazy right now standing up here in
front of all you guys
that's how it led my speech something
like that um and so leaning in on that
has helped has helped me it's a lot more
real
you know it's a lot more real you don't
feel like you have to be fake you can
just lean in on the thing that makes
your heart go crazy like this lean in on
it if you were to make a video to say
i want to tell you my story
if i go back to the landscaping company
i want to tell you why i do what i do
and normally i hate making videos and
this makes me really anxious and nervous
and i'm scared to do this but
landscaping is just so important
it's so important to me because and then
you tell the story with the mom wouldn't
you want to hire that person wouldn't
you want to pay more for that person
right so
leaning in
on your story on the thing that you're
worried that you're going to get judged
for is the way that you're going gonna
win rule number seven take immediate
action take some kind of immediate
action
most people's immediate action is
research
planning
that's not enough immediate action is
doing you have to do something
and you don't know where to start
this is the next thing i don't know
where to start i want to start a youtube
channel i don't know where to start you
start by pulling out your phone and
making a video i'm in my car
on my phone making a video you can too
it's not worrying about it being perfect
it's expecting to suck and just start
just create
i call it the two percent difference but
like what's the first two percent on
your idea we plan to get to 100
instead of just going and doing
something on the first two percent
whatever that big idea is
start to teach yourself that your ideas
are amazing that the ideas that flow to
you are good
they're good for you they're good for
your family they're good for your
community they're good for the world
they're good and you have a duty to
start doing something towards them
start to train yourself on this uh
recently i wanted to learn about nfts
and cryptocurrency and i've dabbled and
learned a little bit but i just decided
i'm going to figure this out
and
last week on friday i spent the day
learning it and i had all sorts of
obstacles thrown in my way i
couldn't get money out of my bank
account because my bank blocked crypto
currency purchases my visa block
cryptocurrency purchases there's a whole
bunch of restrictions as a canadian to
buy from the different exchanges
all sorts of problems all sort and you
know what like one problem after another
after another my my us bank account like
well i've got a us account with td so
i'm gonna go
to my us account no problem
the td was closed the online banking
had a had a update that their website
crashed like oh my gosh like non-stop
but we figured it out built some
momentum
started taking some kind of action
it makes a huge huge huge difference
because while you're feeling the bold
energy if you wait till tomorrow you
won't feel the energy anymore you can
have the perfect plan
but tomorrow you won't have the same
mindset and so you won't execute the
plan rule number eight get close to
customers try to get as close to
customers as possible so it's great to
be making it's big it's great to be
creating it's great to be you know
imagineering of where you could go
when you start to solve the problem for
yourself that's a great step one because
there's probably a lot of people who
currently are who you used to be and
seeing how you solved it for yourself
sharing the videos i need the videos for
myself and then i share them and it
helps other people right so i solve the
problem for me first you solve the
problem for you first i know there's
lots of people like you but
you need to start talking to customers
you need to start getting their feedback
you need to start seeing what they
interact with and that can help guide a
lot of your future product or service
creation you need to get out of just
sitting by yourself on your couch
researching and into actually talking to
people so a quick example from my
channel
the whole top 10 rules of success thing
came because i just made one video on
kanye west that's why he's you know on
the wall behind me made one video on him
and then people started requesting more
hey can you do dame dash hey can you do
jay-z hey can you do jeff bezos hey can
you do steve jobs hey can you do these
people and
it's like well that's a cool idea
sure why not i could do that i never
thought of it as being a whole series i
just was wanted to give a tribute to
kanye west and it was a one-off video
and then in the videos that people were
suggesting can you do this person this
person this person this person i still
get final say we ended up having over
2000 different requests for people to
profile i still get final say as to who
we profile
because i have to feel connected to the
message and when i'm pulling out the
content if we're doing kanye west or
steve jobs it's always something
positive it's always through the lens of
belief because that's what i want to put
out i don't want to put out kanye west's
biggest attacks or insults or
negativity i want to put out negativity
in the world i could easily done top 10
top 10 kanye west stupidest things
you've ever done i'm not interested in
putting that out
so it's that combination of what people
are asking for hey can you do this can
you do that can you do this plus what i
love doing right what i want to put my
stake in the ground and say i made this
right this is the contribution that i'm
trying to make to the world back to the
entrepreneur's success formula right
what you love doing
with what brings value to other people
so how to figure out what brings right
to other people you have to get as close
to the customers possible understand
their business understand what they're
going through understand their mindset
you solve the problem for yourself is a
good first step and then going into okay
what are you struggling with rule number
nine be consistent books give you access
to mentors who you'd never have access
to if you
are struggling thinking i don't have
connections i don't know anybody who's
had success i don't have any good
mentors everybody talks about mentorship
and how important it is and i don't have
anybody in my life to help me
books could be that for you
books can be an accumulation of of
sometimes decades of knowledge all
condensed down into 200 300 400 pages
that you get a window into somebody
else's life
and so whatever you don't
know yet whatever you want to learn
chances are it's in a book it's in
videos as well i love youtube but it can
be in books
there is no excuse not anymore for you
not to get access to the information and
be around the people
that can take you to where you want to
go i'm a big believer that you're a
product of your environment you know
think about who you're hanging out with
where you are right now
where you spend your time
what information are you feeding into
your brain the fact that you're here
watching this video is already a step up
is already showcase that you
are an achiever and that you want more
out of life that you you don't want to
stay where you are that you don't want
to be in the same spot think about one
year from today you don't want to still
be where you are right now right you
want growth you want progress you want
impact you want to touch people's lives
that's why you're here
it just needs to be more consistent it
just needs to be more thorough you know
there's a
expression of the fastest way to learn
language is to go to the country the
fastest way to learn japanese is to go
to
japan and if you can't actually go to
japan then you try to make your
environment as much japanese as possible
you watch japanese tv you read japanese
books you go to japanese restaurants try
to order in japanese you start hanging
out with japanese people you take online
japanese classes you watch japanese
youtube channels like you try to be
around it as much as possible and for
too many of us we're not doing as much
you know are you consistent in watching
inspector videos every morning i make
them every morning for you but you're
probably not watching them every morning
are you consistent in your other habits
and your other routines in the books
that you're reading and the the content
you're consuming like are you consistent
enough and that's usually the problem
is that you have these moments where
you're bold and you're ambitious and
like i'm tired of this life and i want
to do better and this is the day and so
you have the energy and motivation and
you go off and do the thing but then
tomorrow you wake up and it's just not
there anymore you don't stay consistent
on the habit
and the only difference between the
people who've had tons of success and
and where you're at right now is that
they just kept doing it
they just stayed consistent on the habit
and so
if you look at reading as an example i
used to read a ton
before youtube came out before videos
i'm a visual learner i'd much rather
watch something than than read it but
there was no youtube there were no real
videos to learn from so i started with
books and now i've come back to books a
little bit where i'm i'm trying to read
10 pages a day so the goal is 10 pages a
day and i've been
95 consistent on hitting 10 pages a day
rule number 10 the last one before our
very special bonus clip do the scary
things everyone tells you to think
bigger to dream bigger to 10x your goals
to if you had a million dollars or a
billion dollars what would you do
i think the bigger problem is not that
you can't come up with a bigger vision
for yourself it's the belief that it's
possible that's why i think that lack of
belief is the world's number one problem
for me for for you for all your heroes
and gurus all of them that the lack of
belief in the next thing in your big
vision is the reason why you're not
following through and being consistent
on it
especially for achievers you guys
entrepreneurs you're watching this video
you have big visions you know if we gave
you the challenge of
what is your big goal what is your big
vision what is the life you want to
create
we can get lost in the exercises right
and that clarity is power right sitting
down and writing down your goals and
where do you want to become and where
you're going to be in five years and all
of those things can be great exercises
to get you started to get you thinking
and while we're writing it down here's
what happens while you're writing it
down you actually feel that it's
possible
you've let go of the limitations you've
let go of the restrictions you've let go
of your environment and your situation
said this is what i want to create and
in that moment of boldness you feel like
everything is possible
and then what happens
very quickly afterwards maybe it's 10
minutes after maybe it's an hour after
maybe it's the next day maybe it even
lasts a week you start to look at that
list of where you're gonna be
and you think wow i can't i can't do
that
right does it sound familiar have you
ever set some giant goal for yourself
feeling bold motivated and then the next
day you wake up and say i i can't do
that i'm crazy i was crazy it's not even
you telling your your friends or your
family or
social media it's you telling yourself
that you suck and you can't do it right
that's the inner game that we need to
work on so how do we start to fix it one
i think it starts with
understanding that the ideas that you
come up with when you're feeling bold
powerful inspired motivated are actually
the right ones for you
when you're feeling bold and you come up
with something and maybe that's because
you watched a video or had a good
conversation or read a book or went to a
conference or event
you're for whatever reason you've
stepped outside your current
mindset limitations belief system you've
stepped outside you're you're looking at
you
you're looking at a more confident more
bold version of you
and you come up with an idea that you
want to do
that i believe is actually the best
thing for you
and then your head starts talking you
down because someone like you can't do
it be safe be practical there's no way
you can accomplish it you don't have the
money resources education support system
etc whatever whatever valid you know
these aren't made up excuses
valid reasons
they make sense otherwise you wouldn't
believe them
but that's your job to still go off and
do that scary thing step one is when
you're feeling that boldness and you
come up with an idea understand that
that's actually the best you talking
that's actually the thing you have to go
off and do you have to start building
some momentum towards and your brain
will forever
try to keep you small
this is the challenge that we're not
consistent because we don't believe that
we can do the things that we say that we
want to do
there is one practice
that if you can learn to consistently
implement in your business
it'll change the entire direction it'll
it'll
allow you to accomplish
crazy goals that you never thought were
possible and that is to make data driven
decisions
it sounds super boring for any of the
heart
led passion driven
type a personality entrepreneurs out
there watching looking at data and
looking at numbers and look at
spreadsheets might be the most boring
thing in the world for you
but when the data is coming from your
customers the people consuming your
content the people who you're ultimately
selling to and you get insights into
them it can make a dramatic shift
in how you see your business how you
operate your company and how much money
you start to make i'm a big believer
that you make the big decisions in life
with the heart with the heart and the
small ones with the head big decisions
with the heart small ones with the head
the heart is why do you do what you do
why have you started this business why
is this so important to you what is the
mission you're trying to solve right so
for me i want to solve the world's
biggest problem i want people to believe
in themselves more that's the heart
there's no science attached to it it's
just hard it's just art the heart is art
right it's creation and i love tapping
into that side
and then the small decisions with the
head in that
the things that i do have to work
otherwise i just have a hobby right if
you're only doing art and it has no
value to other people you're not talking
to customers you're not
gauging reactions you're not seeing how
you can get better then
you just have a hobby that doesn't pay
you right which can be fulfilling not
everything has to pay you but if the
goal is to have a business then yeah you
have to get paid otherwise you don't
have a company for very long
if you're only listening to the customer
data and you're only looking for
opportunities but you don't actually
like the thing
then you're also going to lose right
because you're just chasing domain but
you're not
curious enough about you don't care
enough about it you don't have enough
heart for it example in my business if i
were to make the top 10 stupidest things
x person has ever said
that that data wise would blow up
because people would rather consume
negativity and poke fun at somebody and
try to tear somebody down then to learn
and try to improve their own life in
general it's so much easier to to laugh
and poke fun at somebody else and
criticize somebody else instead of
working on ourselves to become better
right entertainment versus education
entertainment is a lot easier to consume
than education
because it requires more work
on your part
so i could do that and the data would
say hey go make these videos
they will do better but it doesn't match
my heart i don't want to do that
so the heart gets the veto power but you
have to still listen to the brain
right so big decisions with the heart
small ones with the brain
so let's bring it back to data-driven
decisions
a lot of people struggle with it because
they don't
know how to make data driven decisions
they don't know what numbers to look at
they don't know how to collect the
information they get quite frankly bored
of looking at the information the data
and so then they make subjective
opinions
and often make the wrong ones
yesterday i'm on a call with the team of
a
somebody super well-known
huge presence you you know you would
know his name
you've heard it inside out i've profiled
him millions of times you know on my own
channel
that kind of narrows it down but i'm not
going to tell you who
so i'm on the call with his team and
we're looking at some of his youtube
videos and the goal is to
reach even more people on youtube great
so we looked at one of the thumbnails
and his team said well
he picked this thumbnail like yeah but
this thumbnail is is just not going to
work like this thumbnail sucks
i'm a best practice from everything i've
seen from doing 12 000 split tests on
youtube thumbnails like this is
with a very high degree of certainty not
a good thumbnail in terms of getting
impact
getting more people to click on it
getting more people to view it
and the team said yeah but he picked
that thumbnail
i agree with you evan i don't like it
either but he picked that thumbnail
okay well here's how you combat that
situation what is his ultimate goal
his ultimate goal is to have more impact
his ultimate goal is to reach more
people
right probably let's you know make sure
we get that right you know if his if his
mom on her death bed said you have to
use this as my thumbnail okay you know
great there's a there's a reason other
than business for
picking that thumbnail but if the goal
of this video if we can agree that the
goal of this video
is to try to reach as many people as
possible to spread your message as wide
as possible yes perfect let me help you
do that
the challenge becomes it's one person's
subjective opinion against another's and
the person who's in charge is almost
always gonna win that fight right the
person who's at the top says i want this
and then somebody underneath says but i
think this would be better
and there's no data to support anything
it's just one subjective opinion against
another the person at the top usually
wins so i said okay here's what you do
you agree that the goal is to get as
many views on the video as possible
in an ethical honest way we're not
clickbaiting we're not doing something
against the brand
let's split test it
so here's what you want to do here's an
idea that i've got let's split test it
for two weeks and see what happens
and
what i've
always found
is that people will listen to the data
when they feel like
you're on the same page when they feel
like you're fighting for the same goal
as them
because if you can then show him
that hey this video this is the case
that you bring
this video
if i change the thumbnail did twice as
bad twice as good right it does twice as
the two x's twice better whatever it
doubles the impact right if you could
bring by changing just the thumbnail
same video by changing the thumbnail
you can get twice as many views here's
the data to show you not just my
subjective opinion but here's the data
to show you here's yours here's what it
did here's the one that we tried for two
weeks just let me drive for two weeks
here's what we tried for two weeks
double the views
double the impact
what do you prefer you tell me what's
more important
do you still want to go with that
because it again you have some other
reason for it and and this isn't said in
a condescending way it's like hey help
me understand
this thumbnail that we tried
double the performance which one do you
want to go with and they always go with
the one that gets better results
the challenge is when you're bringing
the idea
it's just your opinion
and they will almost always trust their
opinion over your opinion until you come
with the data the first is lean in on
service
that i'm here to serve i'm here to help
i'm trying to do something up good
what's the intention behind this thing
you're about to do if you're going to go
on stage or you're going to make a video
you're going to make a video walk into
the park right what's the intention is
the intention to hurt somebody to screw
somebody over to lie to them to cheat no
hopefully not not if you're a fan of
this channel come on now
the intention is good the intention is
positive you want to you want to serve
you want to help you want your message
to hopefully impact somebody's life if
you're selling a product or service yes
you want to make money and you're trying
to solve a problem you're trying to help
people so anytime i make it about
you you know the people watching it i
make it personal
i focus on service instead of focusing
on me how am i received how are how are
you liking me how is that guy who passed
by what is he thinking about me right
when that's that's about me i'm worried
about me i'm in my own head i'm playing
small anytime i can focus on other
people and the value that they're
hopefully going to get at least with the
intention
i wouldn't be
uh maybe so bold or or brave to say no
this is going to be my best video ever
but it's my intention always it's my
intention to try to make the best video
i've ever done and and give as much
value as i can and to serve and
hopefully one person is touched by this
video and it means something to them
right so when you're afraid to do
something
focus in on service
reminding yourself every day of how
amazing you are i think it's one of the
greatest gifts you can give yourself and
it's not about ego it's about confidence
confidence comes from a place of
strength ego comes from a place of
weakness and insecurity so it's time to
step into your confidence and remind
yourself of how amazing you really are
this video is going to help so i used to
have a lot of problems with with
ego versus confidence i used to feel
like who am i
why do people need to hear my story uh i
was profoundly all these different
successful entrepreneurs and people kept
asking where are you how come we can't
see what you're about where did you come
from and i always felt like my story
doesn't matter i'm profiling david
goggins and steve jobs and and all these
people why do you care about i mean sure
i sold my first business how to had an
exit but it's nothing compared to what
all these other people have done and i
always
shrouded it covered it under ego like
well that's such an egotistical thing to
do
but really i was just playing small i
was cheating people the opportunity to
learn to get better to grow from my
story that my story has value it's the
belief
that my story had value that took some
time to really work up even making
videos on my channel
the number one most requested person for
top 10 was me and i resisted for maybe
two years of even making an evan
carmichael top 10 because i just felt
not good enough i felt like that's such
an ego play and not coming from a place
of confidence and yes my message has
impact has meaning can help the world
and the first evan carmichael top 10
came out from my team so my birthday
birthday i think it was my birthday
birthday or christmas my team put
together with the with the support of my
hardcore fans my first top 10.
you wanna watch it i'm a little scared
and that's the one that that went live
on a channel ever since then we've done
a regular series of me being on the
channel but it's it's been a real
progress for me it's been a real
evolution it's taken me a long time and
hopefully you can get there faster this
has been
almost 20 years of me
sharing ideas and content and and slowly
stepping into the light and slowly
building more confidence more belief and
i hope that
with the content i'm making and the
experiences i'm sharing you can get
there a lot faster the world's biggest
problem is a lack of belief that the
biggest problem for me for you for
brendan burchard for everybody is a lack
of belief you believe in yourself to the
extent of what you've done that you can
do it again but you don't believe in the
next step you don't believe that you can
go from here to here
this is why i think everybody has what i
call michael jordan level talent at
something like you're a genius you are
the best in the world at something and
it's not what what you went to school
for it's not what your parents taught
you it's not what the people around you
are doing it's probably something very
very very different and unlike your
parents or grandparents it's actually
possible now because of technology
because of the internet it's actually
possible for you to go off and be this
michael jordan level genius adds
something
you don't need to have the resources you
don't need to have the education you
don't need to have the connection
because it's all the walls have been
broken down and it's only getting easier
but it's still the lack of belief
in the ability to do the thing
people say well i think cancer is the
world's biggest problem great i think
cancer should have been solved by now
the woman who would have solved cancer
is a manager at an accounting firm doing
work that she hates because one she
never believed in herself enough to uh
go down the
route to become a doctor or researcher
uh and two even if she started she
didn't believe in herself enough that
she could be the genius at it the the
michael jordan level genius best in the
world or something and this is this is
what happens we settle we get stuck we
get complacent we we find all these
reasons and excuses why we can't do it
we're really it's just fear and lack of
belief and every time you break through
every every major breakthrough that i've
had in my life has come on the other
side of me believing in myself more that
i could go off and do that thing use the
nose as fuel and i add this in not
because i use it but because i know it
works for a lot of other people and and
i'm channeling tom bill you right now
this is one of the things that tom does
that's he credits to having his success
if you know tom impact theory built a
billion dollar business with with quest
and now has his awesome youtube channel
he has a list
he has a list of all the people who
doubted him who didn't believe in him
and whenever he feels like he really
needs that extra motivation he goes to
that dark place and looks at that list
and say all these people did not believe
in me i'm gonna show them wrong i don't
do that i don't get a lot of power
strength for myself of being in the dark
side of proving somebody wrong
but
i think it can be very beneficial for
people and a lot of people do talk about
it so i wanted to at least give that to
you as an option
use those no's as fuel use that
your mom telling you that you suck and
you can't make it maybe she doesn't say
that you suck but that you can't make it
using your friends or haters online
saying that you're never gonna do it
using that as fuel to say i'm going to
show you and prove you wrong i just
think the danger is if you live in there
for too long if you're only fueled for
the dark side it consumes you if you're
only doing something to prove somebody
wrong
you're never going to stay consistent
persistent enough because it's not a
good enough reason at the core of doing
the thing has to be you love doing the
thing you want to serve right you're
built to serve you want to serve you
want to help you want to help right
but if you have to channel the dark side
every now and then use those noses fuel
to help you get forward then go for it
give it a shot your actions have to map
to your ambitions one of the biggest
challenges people have is figuring out
what does balance look like for you you
don't want to have jeff bezos's calendar
you don't want to have evan carmichael's
calendar either balance looks like
something different to us finding your
version of balance
mapping your actions to your ambitions
and then having the courage and the
confidence to chase that down and apply
it to your life when the people around
you are saying you're nuts you're crazy
that's the juice of life that is where
you'll find peace as well as your
success so as an example let me walk you
through a typical week in the life of
evan carmichael
i like having my morning routine that i
do pretty much every day of the week i
have my evening routine that i'll do
pretty much every day of the week and
then i have different days for different
things i find that if i have one full
day to focus on just one main task i'm
much more productive so on mondays is my
mentoring day and i'm spending the whole
day mentoring the people on my team
we're growing we've got over 25 people
on the team and some people i talk to
every week some people every month some
people every quarter but i spend the
whole day just figuring out how can i
make the people on my team better listen
to heard improve training skills all of
it that's my whole day on monday and all
i'm doing is being in the mentoring zone
tuesday is my youtube day i'm making
videos i'm strategizing i'm planning i'm
creating i'm all in on just making
youtube videos my team doesn't bother me
on tuesdays unless it's an urgent
emergency they're not connecting with me
on tuesday because i'm in youtube mode
wednesday is my project day i work on
the things that i want to do to grow my
business whatever project is on my mind
right now so
right now build to serve right getting
the book out promoting it
working on my email campaigns and
sequences and finals and all of that is
most of wednesdays thursdays is my
public facing day that's when i'm doing
interviews and hangouts and podcasts and
being on people's instagram shows on
youtube shows and radio shows it's all
day it's 25 minutes on five minute break
25 minutes on five minute break my
entire thursday
fridays is my ceo day and so i'm doing
bigger picture projects to help build my
business and grow it forward saturday
becomes fun day saturday is when i spend
the day with my wife normally
i'm planning a new food place for us to
go eat i'm looking at festivals for us
to go to and enjoy
we're in coronavirus time right now so
we're in lockdown but it's basically
non-work day and i'm in charge of
planning a day for myself my wife to
have a fun day that i know she's gonna
enjoy
sunday's family at midday and that's
when we're doing costco and dishes and
laundry and we'll do the dishes more
than just sunday
laundry and cleaning up the condo and
going to home depot or whatever has to
get done that's more kind of on the
admin side and when you have clearly
defined
days for for your life list from my life
it prevents bleed so for example if
you know we really have to go to costco
to get something not on a saturday nope
you have to defend your time you got to
defend your time because other things
will constantly attack in your time if
you're ever at the point where you feel
like everybody has something for you to
do and you have no time for yourself
it's it's your fault you haven't put the
boundaries up you haven't put the gates
up you haven't protected your time
enough with the shield that you have
that's what you need to do on a
consistent basis and say i love you i
respect you i want to help you i want to
work with you this is my time
i can help you over here
and and the caveat is when you show up
for them you're with them act on your
uncomfortable ideas we get great ideas
as entrepreneurs we get great ideas and
especially in moments of boldness and
confidence and courage you get great
ideas it could be when you're in the
shower on an airplane or traveling you
get great ideas for what you want to do
and then you tomorrow you tell yourself
i can't do that that's crazy
that that's too hard that's that's scary
that's uncomfortable
teach yourself to act on your crazy
ideas is how you start to build
confidence because if you come up
against a crazy idea and then you allow
yourself to say well that's too scary
that's too hard that's too difficult i
can't do that what you've taught
yourself is
you don't have courage you've taught
yourself to come up with ideas but then
not trust in yourself and so when you
come up with the next idea you tell
yourself i don't trust myself when you
set a goal for yourself to hit hit some
big goal you don't believe yourself
anymore because all you've done is
taught yourself that you set goals you
have ideas and you never follow through
you've built this identity of i'm
somebody who doesn't follow through
that's what you need to start to destroy
that's what you need to destroy and
squash out of your life that identity of
i don't follow through your ideas are
genius your ideas are amazing this is
why i play bigger choices and help you
get an idea and you're in your awesome
environment act on it do something lean
into the uncomfortable lean into the
things that cause a little bit of your
heart to beat and cause some anxiety
that's how you start to make the shift
deciding your top three goals right now
what are your top three goals most
important things to you right now what
are your priorities the three big things
that have to happen for you what are
they get clear get specific if you don't
know what they are that's why you're not
chasing anything big down
if you even thought about it then then
that's the problem you're stuck in these
small projects for life what are your
three big goals for your business and
your life right now staying in your
cocoon and only hanging around the same
five to ten people if those people are
not more ambitious than you
then you're gonna stay stuck you're
gonna feel good about yourself because
you're pushing everybody and you're
optimistic and and you feel good
relative to where they're at but you
won't be growing
you you are probably the most ambitious
person that you know you you're the most
positive most uplifting most energetic
most ambitious person of any of the
people that you hang out with and that's
great and fulfilling and
you can serve them and help them
but it limits your own growth
you stay stuck and you stay super slow
growing and so you need to inject
people who have a greater belief system
than you into your life to make you
feel like you can grow and continue to
get better and that could be somebody
who's actually in your life quick like
side note if there's anybody in your
life
at all who you've met once twice four
times right doesn't have to be your
family somebody that you've hung out
with and met that made you feel better
about yourself when you left them holy
cow hang on to that person i love to
what i say collect good people hang on
to those people find a way to to do a
business with them find a way to spend
time with them find a way to to hang out
with them with brandon berchard reaching
out to me to do this business together
right like he's finding ways to hang out
with what he thinks is good people so
you know that's that's a tremendous
honor on my part
so if you have anybody like that and
again it's probably not the closest
people to you you have to go on the
fringe of people you have spent some
time with try to spend more time with
them find the reason to do it whether
it's certain the business together
whether it's just having a monthly
coffee together just to connect again do
it
if you don't have anybody like that in
your life don't stress that's why
there's videos that's why there's books
that's why there's podcasts if you
watched if you actually started your day
with an espresso video every day your
life will start to shift you won't
notice it tomorrow or the next day or
the next day but a month later three
months later six months later you're
starting to see i'm i'm thinking bigger
now i'm i'm more bold i'm more confident
i want to do bigger things with my life
well why is that it's because you're
hanging around people who are doing
bigger things with their life even
virtually so i can learn a lot from
brendan who i've met and now doing a
partnership with but also from oprah
winfrey and elon musk and all these
people the more i'm around them the more
they pull me to want to think bigger
focus on progress when you focus on
progress instead of the end result
that's where i think you can keep your
motivation and keep your belief when i
first started making my videos i wasn't
getting any results
right nobody was watching nobody was
commenting i felt like a loser right
nobody cares it's not happening i'm not
getting the results understand that you
very rarely ever get results at the
beginning if you focus on just getting
the results at the beginning you're
likely going to get too discouraged and
quit it's not that the results aren't
important it's just people have a too
short an attention span and when you
focused on the result at the beginning
it is too discouraging and you do give
up instead you focus on the progress are
you getting better are you learning was
your video better than last time did you
show up with more energy than last time
did you have better points than you did
last time was that sales call you did
better than the one last time was your
next test better than it was yesterday
right are you getting better
because if you can say i'm getting
better if you if you're making videos
and you look back
a week later a month later and say man i
still suck but i'm better than i was
a week ago a month ago and you can focus
on the progress at least for me it
really helps fuel my motivation my
belief in myself that hey if i made that
growth from here to here then i can make
more growth from here to here
and at the beginning here's the thing at
the beginning the growth is pretty fast
when you're learning something from from
scratch at the beginning you actually
learn very quickly
it's at the end that it gets harder for
me right now to keep getting better is
harder i don't see as big a return on my
on my progress as evan carmichael growth
from last week to this week from last
month to this month how much better am i
on camera from last month to this month
not that much
it requires even more effort and even
more mentorship and even more practice
and training to get better as when
you're close to the top
at the beginning
you can learn really quickly and there's
a lot of progress the flip side for me
now is there's lots of results
right when you start actually getting
good that's when the results kick in
so then you can start focusing on the
results like hey is this working or not
is this video doing better than the last
one or not because you start getting
some data and results to work with
so at the beginning you're focusing on
the progress am i getting better am i
improving and am i learning is it better
than i was last week and then as that
starts to taper off you might get
frustrated with your progress but good
news
you're going gonna start seeing results
come in and that'll keep you motivated
to keep going as well don't compromise
is an amazing message but too many of
you who are perfectionists will hear
that message and use it as an excuse for
not taking action i'm a firm believer
that planners need to do more and doers
need to plan more and here's the problem
planners do not need to plan more you're
already great at planning you will plan
plan plan plan plan plan plan your life
away and never actually take any kind of
action and so for the perfectionists out
there for the planners who want to have
the perfect plan before you do anything
this is an amazing message but you're
not hearing it correctly it's not don't
compromise on having the perfect plan
and just sit in your room all day and
don't take any action because steve jobs
was a doer
this is a hard lesson that i had to
learn myself because i lost a 40 million
deal in my first business when i was 21
because i was a perfectionist because
everything had to be perfect because i
didn't want to compromise that's how i
interpreted the message but as a result
i didn't do anything
and just kept planning and i lost the
deal became between us and our biggest
competitor
and we were really late to the party
because we didn't do the right thing and
we ended up losing the deal
now would we have won it if i had done
more maybe not 100 but i would have had
a better shot at it and so ever since
then i've been trying to release that
perfectionist habit it's still in there
i still love the plan
but the people who have the most success
have that combination of planning but
then actually doing block the time and
take small losses for big wins
physically put into your calendar
this block of time on monday afternoon
i'm spending on xyz
and i'm okay with losing some small
losses
i will not be reachable i might lose a
deal there might be some burn down
happening that i can't take charge of
i'm going to disappoint somebody i'm
going to let somebody down not with not
with intentionally not on purpose
but it's going to happen
and you're not going to kick yourself
for doing it because what you're gonna
make you're gonna make that time count
those two hours four hours six hours
eight hours however long you're spending
working on your goals you're gonna make
that time count
you're sacrificing all these small wins
that you love going after to make this
time count so use that as pressure
not to feel guilty about yourself for
not doing those little small wins
and being linked and getting back to
people but in saying i am working on
something that's going to change my life
and because of these people who are
dependent on me for everything else and
i'm pushing that off i better make this
time count use that pressure to drive
you forwards instead of backwards
planning doesn't count
planning strategizing making ideas that
doesn't count where you're going to grow
doesn't count you gotta do
you gotta send an email you gotta make a
piece of content you gotta post
something you gotta follow up with
somebody you have to create you gotta
make
instead of just living in your head
right that's how you tell the difference
planning is living in your head models
structured business plans ideas it's
it's amazing i love it i could be there
all day long
but you won't have any kind of impact
just staying up in here
do
every single day adopt the mindset that
you need to do
on a daily basis you have michael jordan
level genius at something you
you you are the greatest the greatest in
the world
at something
and it's probably not what your parents
did or what you went to school for
it's sitting here somewhere deep buried
and you don't believe that you can do it
but until you actually lean in
on what you have michael jordan ability
genius at until you actually start doing
it
you'll never live the life that you're
capable of you'll you'll constantly be
doing
what other people want you to do living
up to other people's expectations
meanwhile knowing that you're capable of
more i often get into fights uh maybe
not fights discussions
maybe arguments with people about when
they're making youtube videos for
example thought leaders i'm i'm deeply
passionate about helping more thought
leaders get onto youtube i want to see
your message out there because i believe
that your message can change the world i
think your message can impact people's
lives that people like you who you used
to be they need to hear your message and
you're you're too scared to get it up
there and one of the biggest
complaints or one of the biggest
objections people have is well i don't
know how to edit i don't know how to
film and what they end up doing is you
spend 20 minutes
making a video recording it and then
five hours editing it
what you're doing there is training the
wrong skill
if you want to make a video like this
right
you're gonna sit in your car i'm still
just making this video off of my phone
right i just have like can you see my
glasses maybe you can see look i've got
a there we go this is cool look i've
just got a little mini handheld
whatever tripod i guess
a selfie stick more like it and in my
phone that's how i'm filming this video
that's it sitting here in the car while
my wife is in costco shopping and
getting some awesome food for us
if you spend 20 minutes making a video
filming it recording it and then five
hours editing it
you're just training the wrong skill
you'll never get great at the thing that
you have michael jordan level ability at
now if you said your ambition is to be
the world's greatest editor that's
different congratulations you're doing
it you're doing it but if you want to be
a thought leader a speaker an expert you
want to you want to learn to make videos
and be the front facing person then
spending 20 minutes on something to
actually improve your skill that's
improving your skill making a video but
five hours editing it you're just
not wasting time but you're you're
stealing from your opportunity
you're stealing from your ability you're
stealing from your best self
okay well what do i do evan what how do
i how do i then create i don't want to
put up something that's bad
the thing that gets you there
is actually getting great at your skill
the michael jordan level skill
i'd rather you spend five hours
making a video doing it again and again
and again and again and again and again
and again so that you don't need
editing
that you're so good at the thing that
you don't need editing
because that's a skill that will serve
you for life
because when you go on stage
you don't get to edit yourself
right there's no second takes when you
go on
tv and you're being interviewed when you
go on people's podcasts you're being
interviewed if you you're teaching
yourself that you're only good when
you're edited
and that's not your michael jordan level
ability this whole seriousness versus
playful thing i agree that it's
important to be playful i think smiling
is great i think having a happy
optimistic positive way of thinking
about things is really important
especially as entrepreneurs because we
have to deal with so much crap and so
much pain so much misery so much
rejection so much other people's
negativity around us that if you are not
playful if you are not joyous then it's
really really hard to keep going on your
mission and it's ultimately why a lot of
people stop and they quit they get
consumed by the negativity and they have
to leave it and go off and do something
else
that being said i also think there's a
time for seriousness i think it can
really help you i think it can help
focus you i think it can help drive you
forward on your mission the way i see
playfulness and seriousness are two
sides of the same coin i think you need
both i think they're not opposite of
each other i think they complement each
other i see it as the same thing as
ambition and gratitude i think you need
to be really ambitious i think it's
important to have big goals and set a
life for yourself that you want to go
off and accomplish and keep striving to
do it
and i think it's important to be really
grateful for everything that you already
do have you are spoiled you are lucky
you are so fortunate just to be alive
just to be living in your country just
be able to watch these youtube videos
there's so much that you have to be
grateful for that you don't even
recognize and so i think both of those
serve each other i think if you are just
overly ambitious and never are grateful
i think it just leads to a really dark
place i think it's never enough and it
just becomes all-consuming and i think
if you're only grateful all the time and
have zero ambition then that's a happy
life but you're not helping others
you're not serving others you're not
fulfilling the potential that you have
inside yourself and so i think of them
as both being necessary i think you need
both of them i think one standalone
doesn't help you get to where you need
to go and so i see that as the same
thing as playfulness and seriousness i
see them as two sides of the same coin i
think you need both of them at different
times to help you go off and be that
best version of yourself you start
thinking about okay i'm not great at
these things
but they need to get done
right some of these things have to get
done first you want to eliminate if it
if you don't have to do it then don't do
it there's some there's some things that
you're doing that actually don't matter
there's some things that i'm doing that
don't matter that you think matter but
then when you analyze like that doesn't
even matter nobody even cares if i do
that thing or not
right just eliminate it don't don't
give it to somebody else if it shouldn't
even be done in the first place you
eliminate it
then you automate it
so automate is look for ways to do it
through software through technology
through tools anything that i'm i'm
doing multiple times like okay how do i
how do i make this more automatic so
that i don't have to be doing this all
the time
and if you can't eliminate it and you
can't automate it then you delegate it
and delegate as you give it to somebody
give it to somebody who that's their
michael jordan level genius
editing these videos i have an amazing
team you know christina hi christina is
amazing
and that's her michael jordan level
genius she makes amazing videos she can
edit way way way better than i ever
could let alone than what
i can do right now and when you find
people who they are the michael jordan
level
of the thing that you suck at that's
when you can really start to explode now
you might be you might not be able to
afford them
yet
so what can you do well one you get
uh people who can volunteer
who can
maybe do some kind of barter like
entrepreneurship is about being
resourceful
what can you offer them
and what can they offer you what kind of
trade can you make if you have no money
what kind of trade can you make instead
of saying well i just i don't have money
to hire somebody so i'm just going to do
it myself
you have to start being more strategic
you have to start thinking okay what am
i
what am i so fantastic at what is your
michael jordan level ability and how can
that be of value to somebody else that
in exchange for me helping them they can
help me with this thing
that's how entrepreneurship works
the ones who really really win they're
not the ones who do it all themselves
they're the ones who are resourceful to
find ways to bring on a team
right the ones who are ultra successful
number two schedule your due time what i
want you to do is plan for one hour
every single day if you're an
entrepreneur one hour every day where
you're doing pick a time ideally i think
morning like if you get in at nine the
nine to ten first hour of the day but if
it's not then blocking the account this
is important
this is what will change your life this
is what will change the trajectory of
your business if you are stuck
constantly and just responding to people
in plain planning perfectionist mode
do time right we said do it daily point
number one now you got to schedule it in
just have an intention won't do anything
if you're not actually taking action on
it right you're not doing the thing that
you promise to do you're not doing the
doing the progress that you will make
the closer you get to your goals will be
a reflection of what you are putting in
your calendar what you are actually
doing so i want you to schedule one hour
today of due time every single day we're
gonna be making something and pushing it
up to the world you can't feel grateful
and sad at the same time you can't feel
grateful and upset at the same time you
can't at the same time feel grateful and
hurt
vengeful rage you can't gratitude is the
opposite emotion the opposite expression
of all of those things so whenever
you're feeling low down negative hurt
upset
the answer is gratitude
i don't like staying in
negative emotions for too long the only
one is grief you know i think the only
one that i
let
happen is grief
because i think you just have to work
your way through it i don't want to
trick myself out of grief because
you're feeling it for a reason i don't
actually think it's a negative emotion
i think
you have to just work your way through
it but everything else
upset anger hurt jealousy rage think
about all the other negative emotions
that you experience i don't want to stay
in them for too long they don't serve me
they don't serve you they don't allow
you to show up as your best self and so
the fastest way out is gratitude because
there's always something that you can be
grateful for it's just a perspective
shift if i was sitting here in the car
feeling upset or feeling sorry for
myself or down on myself uh i can always
think back to man
i used to make 300 bucks a month and
feel
like i wasn't doing anything
that i was bringing no value that wasn't
contributing anything
and now i get to i get to sit in this
car i get to sit in this car
right that little shift
can make all the world of difference i
was talking to jeremy yesterday on my
team and jeremy is an entrepreneur
invested into
what 18 months ago i guess he used to
have a job working at a grocery store
hating his life knowing who's capable of
more earning minimum wage
and just
not liking what he was doing at all
and now he's he's built over half a
million dollar business a year
doing youtube consulting based off of
what i teached him teached him taught
him taught him and continue to teach him
you know he's got a half a million
dollar plus business now and we're
talking yesterday it was a little down
because
you know the client who left him and and
that happens right any client service
business you get bad news clients will
leave you you will at some point
underperform you will disappoint people
that's gonna happen and that and
my job is to help give more perspective
to say dude
it's okay you're you're still great
look at what you've built in the past
the 18 months look at where you were you
used to be a grocery store clerk
now you're working with amazing people
helping them build their channels
getting paid insane amounts of money
compared to what you're used to like how
much money do you have in your bank
account compared to where you were 18
months ago how much more fulfilled are
you in the work that you're doing right
now compared to where you used to be 18
months ago right how much of your world
has changed so don't get too down
because the down doesn't serve you most
people can't handle radical honesty we
can't handle it because we're too caught
up in other people's opinions we care
too much
about what other people think about us
we're so insecure that if you actually
got honest feedback you'd feel like
you suck as a human not that
you just have an area that you need to
work on we can't separate between
skills that we need to work on and us
the fact that we suck at a skill we
interpret as we suck as a human because
we care too much of what other people
think which is why radical honesty is
not something that we generally lead
with but until you get to the point
where you can have that both with
yourself and at least with the closest
people around you until you get there
you won't have fulfilling deep
meaningful honest relationships when i
think about radical honesty i think
about it in two ways one of giving it be
able to give honest feedback and then be
able to receive it
two different sides of the coin that i'm
going to break down in this video so in
terms of giving it
we would love to be able to give more
honest feedback right how many people in
your life would you love to have a more
honest conversation with and tell them
what's really on your mind you don't
because
you're afraid of how they're gonna react
you're afraid that they're gonna
get hurt they're gonna freak out they're
gonna judge you more they're gonna
they're gonna run away whatever you're
afraid you're afraid of the reaction and
so
the way around that is to show love
when you give honest feedback to
somebody the
initial
reaction is negative because they feel
judged
that's really at the core of it like
they feel that you are judging them they
don't feel the love so you have to leave
with love
the more that they feel loved that then
you give the feedback they know it's
coming from a loving place they're much
more receptive get used to releasing
imperfect things it doesn't mean that
you settle for crap
that's not the message it's not just
okay this sucks we're gonna release it
and not care about it anymore
by releasing the perfect things though
and then tweaking it and getting better
you are getting used to doing you're
getting used to not just holding on to
your perfect concepts and perfect dreams
forever for me an example could be to
make
make imperfect videos you know do
instagram stories and if i make a
mistake i post it if i make a mistake i
try to make it into into something fun
when i was in boston i was trying to say
we're going to go see some dim sum we're
going to a dim sum restaurant and say
we're going to go to
right i stumbled on my words and i made
it into something fun and i released it
like yes that's the best put that out
there perfectionists need to get used to
losing the perfectionist
habit
and it won't ever go away it's always
the it's always the big fear that i
don't want to become a slob i don't want
to let myself go i don't want to release
garbage out to the you won't you'll
never be that person you'll never stop
caring
but you just need to lose the
perfectionist habit a little bit
because you will never be perfect
the stuff you release will never be
perfect you will always look back at
what you made and say it could be made
better and that's awesome that's your
greatest strength but it's also your
greatest vulnerability it's your
greatest weakness so getting used to
once a week releasing something that
isn't perfect it's the best that you
could make within the time allotted
once a week every week release that
within your own industry so for me be
making a video do a snapshot tour for me
it's daily three to five times a day but
at least once a week and when it sucks
when you made a mistake
when you want to delete it when you want
to say of course i can't post that i
can't sell that i can't put that out
there as soon as you're about to hit the
delete button boom that's when you post
it and feel the fear and the nervousness
and the craziness and like oh my gosh i
can't believe i just did that that
sucked and then release it
so you know what that wasn't actually
that bad like what's the response it's
not not actually that bad and when you
can get used to releasing imperfect
products and keep your drive to make
perfect products that's when ultimately
you will win to move from planning mode
into the doer mode people will not
understand what you're trying to do if
you are
an entrepreneur with a big dream a big
mission a big vision some big goals for
yourself
people won't understand
what you're trying to do if everybody
understands you're thinking way too
small
if everybody's like yeah that makes a
lot of sense yeah oh that that's exactly
like this you're thinking too small your
potential your vision is bigger than how
you're explaining it
at the beginning it should be difficult
for people to wrap their head around
what you do it should be difficult to
explain
who you are if somebody asks you at a
networking event or some party hey what
do you do i think it should be difficult
for you to explain who you are i think
that's fantastic i think that means
you're actually living your life instead
of living inside some box that is easy
to understand i look at my
history and i've been on youtube since
2009 my first video
and
at the time youtube was not
what it is today it was not an
educational platform there weren't
really people doing
entrepreneur videos
educational videos long form videos it's
just a totally different beast and it
took five years to get the 7 000
subscribers on my main channel five
years
7 000 subscribers
i remember one of the videos that
i loved the most
i was so proud i spent the most amount
of effort and collaboration time in
creating this video
and
it was it was a
long video it was six minutes
it was a six minute video back in the
day so this long video
and i showed it to somebody when i was
basically ready to release it i showed
it to somebody who was in the industry
who's not in the youtube industry but in
the in the video industry
and
i showed it to him and i said hey what
do you think like i'm i'm pretty happy
with this video do you have any thoughts
feedback suggestions and he just didn't
want me to publish it he said nobody's
going to watch a video that's six
minutes long nobody
that just it's just way too long
nobody's going to watch it
he told me that i didn't understand how
the internet worked
and just i don't know just poured into
me i shared some of the exact quotes in
in your one word my first book of what
of what he said to me and he was an
expert right he was somebody who was it
wasn't just some guy off the street he
was a guy who was in thought leadership
did a lot of video content and him
telling me that this would never work
and it was too long that i didn't
understand how things work and a younger
you know less experienced seven might
have listened to him
but at the time i felt okay
i don't know maybe he's right but i
spent a lot of time on this thing
and i liked it
it it
moved me it inspired me so whatever i'll
just post it who cares if it ends up
being a giant flop then lesson learned
maybe it'll inspire you know a couple
hundred people and
i had fun doing it
right
and so we released it
and at the time my best video had a
hundred thousand views in a year and i
was so proud of that video man a hundred
thousand hundred thousand views
in a year that's awesome
this video launched and i did a hundred
thousand views in a month
it ended up being my best video on the
channel
uh it's not anymore but
was the best bit in my channel for
maybe a couple years
[Music]
now it's got you know a couple million
views on it
and
it's just a reminder that
i'm trying to do
something
big
you are where you are because of your
environment the easiest way to change
where you are right now in life if
you're not happy you want to change
where you are right now in life the
easiest way to do it is to change your
environment change who you hang out with
change the videos that you watch change
what you wear change where you go change
your habits when you change your
environment it automatically triggers
new thoughts new beliefs new mindsets
inside you where if you hang out with
the people who are not living the life
that you want you're watching the videos
of people who are tearing each other
down instead of educating and lifting
people up when you're constantly
surrounded by
negativity and small-mindedness guess
what you become
if you can switch it if you can choose
consciously to make a change in your
environment towards a better life that
life will start to manifest
so when i was on my tour
in 2019 it was the first time i got to
meet john astrap i was going to san
diego and john's team
heard that i was doing my tour and i
said hey if you're coming to san diego
would you like to interview john for
your channel
uh yeah yeah yes i would
yes i would like to do that very much
how do we make that happen
and
we we scheduled it it was not part of my
initial
tour
we had to move things around to make
that happen and we had the fortune to
spend i don't know half of a day with
john we went to his office
neurogym we did the interview we hung
out we talked about youtube uh met his
team
and
there's the knowledge exchange which is
great where i got to ask him questions
and hang out and we we i don't know how
long we spent there on the actual
interview but more important is the
energy exchange more important is when
you're hanging around somebody who's
accomplished a lot it it makes you want
to do more
you know when you're around people who
are more fit than you it makes you want
to be more fit when you're around people
who have a great relationship it makes
you want to have a better relationship
when you're around people who've had
success in business it makes you want to
have more success in business and
the challenge and a big reason why i
make all of my content is because
you are probably the most ambitious
person that you know
you're the most ambitious positive happy
uplifting person in your circle and
that's fantastic and that's a gift that
you give to other people because you're
encouraging and lifting them up but
there's nobody
pulling you forward there's nobody who
you're hanging out with who says you
could be doing more and so hanging out
with john ashraf and at his place in san
diego was another extra push it's like
this is
this is something that i want more of
these are the people that i want to hang
out more with even though i'm
introverted and shy and don't like
introduce myself to people and
think that i suck at networking
it's still important to spend as much
time as possible with the people who
inspire you to live a better life
whatever that version of your life is so
i'd encourage you to look at your your
calendar look at your schedule look at
what you're doing right now look at how
you're spending your time
how much of it is actually dedicated to
the thing that you could be the greatest
in the world at
and for too many people it's it's
not enough for too many people it's zero
you have ideas and hopes and dreams and
ambitions and goals but there's nothing
in your calendar we're actually spending
time focused on it
the best thing you can do to set you up
for a life of happiness fulfillment
purpose income all of it
is to
drastically change what's in your
calendar
to spend more time developing
your michael jordan level skill
ability
genius
period you are what you consistently do
the problem for people watching this
video for you your problem
is that you know where you want to go
you know what you want to accomplish you
actually even know the habits that you
need to do
you're just not doing them consistently
you get motivated you get inspired you
get pumped up something happens in your
life that then makes you want to go and
drive further harder faster let's go
and then you fall off the track
you go back to the old ways you go back
to your old habits
and then you don't end up accomplishing
your goals even though you know you're
capable you know what's possible you
know you could do it you have done
versions of it in the past but you're
not consistent on it that's the problem
and that's what we need to shift in this
video because until you get off that
loop you're going to keep running the
same cycle over and over and over and
over again knowing that you're capable
of more
knowing that you've got the potential
hard to accomplish amazing things
to serve to make a lot of money
to be the person that you want to be
knowing that that's possible but them
never actually accomplishing it we're
going to fix that in this video so i've
got a a model of the four stages of
personal development or four stages of
personal growth
and the first one is the haters and the
haters are the people who hate their own
life and this is most people most people
don't actually love their own life if
you
really
dug down and analyze people you ask them
about themselves and how much they love
their life most people will not love
their life most people do not have
positive self talk when they're looking
in the mirror most people over judge
themselves uh over criticize themselves
and know that they're not living the
life that they could be living that's
most people most most of the world hates
their life and it shows up especially in
america in in depression rates and
suicide rates like people are not happy
people are not happy and as a result
they're in a lot of pain and as a result
of that they they hate on other people's
ideas if you're thinking why so many
people will tear down your ideas and
tell you why you can't do it
because they are in a lot of pain
themselves
because they maybe took a shot at their
life their dream life and it didn't
didn't happen they didn't they didn't
make it so now nobody around them can be
happy either
right this is the problem i'm trying to
solve you know i'm trying to move people
from the land of haters because i
believe people are good
you know i believe people are good
people are good people want to serve
you're built to serve you want to serve
you want you want to help people are at
the core good and yet
a lot of people are are negative
because they're in a lot of pain so
that's step one and that's probably not
if you're watching this video if you're
subscribed to this channel that's not
you you're not the hater but you know
probably a lot of people who are haters
and you can join me on my mission to to
save them to serve them to help them to
shift them to move them forward to
realize that their dream life is
possible whenever you don't know what to
do
the best thing you can do is model
success
find the person or the people who've
done the thing that you want to do
learn how they did it apply it to your
situation so you can achieve similar
results and get to your goal
otherwise you're constantly bouncing
around between idea to idea to idea to
idea constantly trial and error trial
and error trial and error and you might
run out of time and it might actually
get too late where if you can model
success the the biggest shortcut to
success is to model
find the people who've done it
understand how they did it apply it to
your life this is the thing that changed
my life
i i quit on my business partner i was 19
years old
me 20 at that point i quit on my
business partner
i was just tired of things not working i
was tired of the business being so slow
and sluggish and
not getting results and making no money
i was tired of it i was
everything before that that i applied
myself to i got a result and here i was
trying trying every day trying showing
up to the same
place she went into my business
partner's living room every day
working from this dining room table
every day and just
not getting results
and i was tired of it so i quit
and then i woke up the next day and
realized i don't want to quit i can't
quit yet i can't quit it's
i'm gonna regret this
but i can't keep doing it the way i'm
doing it and so
the genius moment out of pure
desperation
was
somebody has done this before
i asked myself who has done this before
who has built a software company before
who's done that i'm trying to solve this
problem
i don't feel like i'm an idiot
although i kind of feel like
like an idiot right now because i'm
trying so many things
i know i'm not stupid somebody's done
this before can't be this hard who's
done this
and that's where i thought of bill gates
who started microsoft and
he's just one of many he could have been
anybody in software he was just the only
person i could think of at the time
and i learned his story and found out
how he did it and applied those
strategies through him through
partnership so i thought okay let me get
some partnerships
and i got my first deal i've said for
thirteen and a half thousand dollars
a little while after and
that changed everything for me that
changed the business that
that made me stay in it that gave me
hope that made me feel
not worthless that made me feel like
things were possible
that gave me growth in the company and
it also gave me a strategy for the rest
of my life and that whenever i don't
know what to do
the best thing to do is to model success
the biggest problem
with wannabes is
you're watching a video or you're going
to an event and you think that that's
the work that's not the work
that doesn't matter until you actually
do something watching this video doesn't
mean anything unless you actually take
action on it right nothing changes in
your life until you actually take action
on it watching this video going to
somebody's event listen to somebody's
podcast might get you inspired
right it might get you thinking about
what's possible
about where you could go
but it doesn't actually lead to you
doing anything until you do something as
entrepreneurs we're mission driven right
you want to solve a big problem you want
to make a huge change in the world so
remind yourself of what the mission is
and how grateful you are to be on this
path even if you're not where you want
to be yet
you're not doing what you want to do
fully yet but you never are there you
never when you hit that goal you
you want a bigger goal and i think
that's great so you're on your journey
and you're much more
fulfilled on that journey than you used
to be compared to who you used to be
compare your life to where you were five
years ago or ten years ago
the awareness education you've gone
through the the the purpose the heart
that you've now
discovered and tapped into on a deeper
level
for me i'd be thinking about
helping entrepreneurs
i get to everyday wake up
and help entrepreneurs i get to make
videos i get to make content i get to
influence people i get to
i get to try to
help 18 year old evans out there who's
struggling
with their first business
right
for you what's your big mission
and how can you tap into it and feel it
and it may not have to take too long to
do it but just close your eyes and
actually feel that you touch somebody's
life
again it may not be the scale that you
want it's never the scale you want but
you touch somebody's life
if one person left a comment on your
video one person left a thumbs up
on your post you touched one person's
life
tap into what that feels like
that you had a meaningful impact on them
today i would have been the guy who
10 years ago would have thought that's
not possible for me i'm just introverted
shy kid who
um
just is not a type a personality and
doesn't like networking and will never
meet these people so
step one
consume their content even if you never
meet these people just having them
around you daily allows you to start to
shift and start to think like them
allows you to start to adopt their
mindset because they're saying things
that are different than the people in
your life
john ashraf is saying something
different than your parents
right
he's thinking a different way than your
friends he's thinking on a higher level
than a lot of the people probably in
your life right now
and so the more that you're around that
virtually by watching videos even if you
never meet him the more you start to
think bigger to have more ambition to
believe that it's possible so part of
your daily routine must must must be
to consume the content of the people who
inspire you to want to be bigger
uh that's why i make this espresso video
that's why i make all of my content on
all of my channels
but if it's not my videos if it's books
if it's podcasts
something it's got to be daily though
just like you brush your teeth daily you
need to inject
positivity and belief daily from people
who are doing more than you right you're
brushing your teeth helps you with your
dental hygiene we need to work on our
mental hygiene it's really really
important because the
the mental hygiene will take care of
itself in a negative way based off your
current environment
if you are if you are just constantly
battling
negativity around you or
small-mindedness around you and there's
nothing that comes into your life that
feeds you with hope and positivity and
inspiration in the sense you could do
more there's nothing in that in your
life right now then you won't go off and
do it and so step one is to just be
around the content
every single day
in micro doses every single day
my new routine right now is i go for a
walk in the morning
and it's about 40 to 45 minutes in the
morning and i
i watch my own videos i watch my top 10
videos
while i go for the walk so this morning
i was watching
lewis howe's video and a garyvee video
that i made for my channel and every
time i do it i pick up something new it
it's a fantastic way to start my day if
you could start your day
every day with garyvee or lewis howes or
john aserath or oprah or elon musk or
whoever your your life will change
it's why i do these espresso videos i
want to give you the shot of espresso
every morning your life will change if
you start your day every day with the
people who inspire you they will pull
you up and you don't notice it on a
day-to-day basis but if you look back a
week a month three months six months a
year if you did it every day for a year
holy cow you will be a totally different
person there is always a way there is
always a way there is always a way there
is always a way there is always a way
when you feel stuck when you feel
hopeless when you feel like the world is
against you and you've got big ambitious
goals remind yourself there is always a
way there is always a way
entrepreneurship is always about how
resourceful you are instead of the lack
of resources this is where people get
caught up you wish you had more money
you wish you had a different education
you wish you had different parents you
wish you lived in a different country
you're so focused on the things that are
not going right in your life instead of
focusing on what can i do with what i do
have there is always a way
wife has to go shopping on filming day
great i'll film in the car
with timo hi teemo high five woo good
boy
he's so cute
business shuts down my dance studio
closes down because of covet great move
online like there's always a way i was
telling my friend mark about
uh how i got the honest company for my
book your one word so i don't know three
four five years ago i don't know how
long ago how long ago when did your wine
come out it doesn't matter
i wanted to get the honest company
because they built their business around
their one word honesty and they were you
know 100 million dollar plus company
wanted to interview them there was only
one big problem i didn't know them i had
no connection in
and i wrote in and i didn't hear back
and i really really wanted the company
so
there's always a way remind yourself
there's always a way so what i did was i
wrote to techcrunch and techcrunch at
the time was the biggest
blog slash website slash news site for
the tech industry and i said hey
i messaged the
the managing editor who i did not know
either right just cold out of the blue
said hey i'm writing a book
and i'd love to do an interview with the
honest company
and
if i did an interview with the honest
company
would you publish it and we're going to
talk about these topics
and he said yes
just interviewed the managing editor out
of the blue and he said yes
great now i can go back to the honest
company and say hey i want to do an
interview with you for my book and for
techcrunch
and that got me in the door
right and that then that led to me doing
the interview and flying to california
and meeting christopher gavigan who's an
amazing human uh and doing the interview
and
getting my book done
and so
i didn't know the honest company i
didn't know
techcrunch
i had no connections in
but you remind yourself there's always a
way and that's how you do it you find a
way
what can you do with what you do have
right now how can you be a resource how
can you be an asset how can you help the
people around you so that you can move
closer to accomplishing your goals as
well so how do you do it you know it's
easy to say great evan uh you don't
understand me i'm stuck in the situation
right now how do i get out of it
everybody's against me i tried a million
i tried everything i tried everything
and it's not working how do i get out of
it it's a couple things you need to do
number one if you are stuck kind of in
the middle of it if you are stuck
feeling overwhelmed feeling it's not
possible feeling
just you've tried everything and you're
gonna give up
step number one is
you have to take a break from where you
are right now
go outside go for a walk breathe
meditate because when you're in when
you're in the lowest of the low
me saying be more resourceful there's
always a way you can't actually hear it
you're not ready for the message yet
because you're too low
this is why a lot of us when we're
trying to help other people the people
around us
and telling them you're gonna make it
you can be great they can't hear it
because they're too low so you have to
get them back to normal state you have
to get yourself back to a normal state
so that comes from from getting outside
your environment right now go for a walk
get some fresh air do some breathing
meditate pray whatever you need to do to
get back to a normal state so you're not
a depressed human but you can actually
be open and receptive to a message i'm
here making videos for you
because that's part of my routine
you know i'm recording this on a tuesday
every tuesday i make videos every
tuesday i make videos every tuesday i
make videos every tuesday i make videos
i made videos
feeling sick i made videos with no voice
and i held up signs i made videos with a
concussion and a broken neck i make
videos that's the difference between an
achiever and a high achiever
is that you show up when everybody else
would give you a break when everybody
else would say take it easy when
everybody else would say you're pushing
too hard everybody else says you're too
obsessed
you say
no i'm committed to my goals i'm
committed to making this happen
because you are what you consistently do
we tend to try to over correct things
if you
have a goal of eating a certain number
of calories they're sticking to a
certain weight
and you go and you binge one day we tend
to try to over correct to say that's it
i'm going on a 24-hour fast you know i'm
just not going to eat anything for 24
hours or if your business
you let yourself down you don't deliver
you don't promise you don't follow
through on the promises you say you're
going to make videos for youtube and
then you don't do it and then the next
day you wake up say i'm done with that
i'm going to make 80 videos today or
whatever the number would be we tend to
try to do too much in the short run
and that's not where the gains are made
right you could go to the gym and and
have an amazing session
but if you're not consistently showing
up to the gym you're not going to get
the results that you want same thing for
the gym of life the gym of business the
gym of of your mindset it's what you do
consistently every single day
and that can sometimes be boring
and that can sometimes be that you're
chasing the wrong thing you're doing
somebody else's routine instead of your
own but if you want to be a high
achiever if you want to show up
for yourself for your family for the
people around you for your customers the
people who know you can serve you want
to show up as your best self every day
for them
the key
is that you stick to your habit try to
be a person of value
being a person of value means what does
this person care about and how can you
help support it so if you're trying
to be a person of value to me
what am i what do i care about right now
you know the easiest thing to do is look
at my instagram bio look at my twitter
bio look at the things that i'm
promoting right now right now
if uh right now i'm talking about build
to serve a lot it's still something i
care deeply about right now i'm talking
about movement makers i'm talking about
brand lytics these are the programs that
i'm launching that i care a lot about
so how can you help me with that
what does john ashraf launching go look
at his instagram bio his twitter buy
what is he promoting right now that's
what he cares about right now to be a
person of value you want to be the
person's chief goal officer what do they
need right now what are they promoting
right now what are their goals right now
and then finding some way to help them
even if it's just being
the best person in the comments
right
i have an amazing community you guys are
amazing
it's what makes me want to keep making
content because of how fantastic you
guys are and there are some people who
watch the videos and then never
leave any any comment
leave comments guys there are some
people who watch a video and leave a
comment and then there are the special
few who watch a video leave a comment
but then we'll also comment on the other
comments not in a promotional way not
just saying hey check out my new channel
i've worked really hard on it let me
know sub for sub but in a
in an encouraging positive optimistic
way in just trying to cheer the other
people on and supporting them
those people are extra special and there
are
there are some people who
i would do the best that i could to try
to support them i get hit up every day
with different promotional opportunities
hey evan can you link this up can you
shout me out can you check out my
business plan and it's usually a no
because i don't even know who you are
but there are other people who have
brought so much value to my community
that
i would
i would do my very best to try to help
them
because of how much they've helped me
even though they may not have ever
bought anything that i've done just
because they were so valuable in the
community
right so that's your goal your goal
is to be a person of value to be the
chief goal officer and then be a person
of value to them and their community so
they start to recognize you if you don't
like something in your life
you can change it
this is why we become entrepreneurs
because we don't like something that's
going on in our lives in the in the
world you know the people around us we
don't like the way something is done
and we're committed to change it that's
why entrepreneurs are gonna solve all
the world's major problems we're not
waiting on government we're not waiting
on big corporations it's us we're gonna
we're gonna sell the problems you you
are gonna sell the problems if you don't
like something
when most of the world is stuck in
complaining and blaming and mediocrity
and unhappiness and excuses and i'm too
old and i'm too young and i don't have
the resources and blah blah blah but
most of the world is stuck in that
you're off
saying i'm going to make a change
i'm going to make that happen
and it's just the mindset shift that you
have to make and keep and sustain on a
daily basis because
it's so easy to fall back down into
limited thinking into fixed mindset into
mediocrity to feel like ugh i can't do
this
maybe maybe it can't happen maybe it's
not for me maybe i'm not the person
maybe i'm not good enough maybe i don't
belong maybe
it works for other people but not for me
right it's so easy to go back to that
zone
but if you don't like something
in your life or your community or the
world
you can change it
be the change you want to see in the
world that's you what do we learn to be
great managers you don't learn it in
school
you'll probably not be a great manager
at the beginning so i think the best way
to get going is to actually hire
somebody part time the first person i
hired was for one hour a day
one hour a day i hired them for one hour
a day one they were better at at the
thing it was doing database stuff than
than i was so it freed up an hour and a
half of my time every day
because he was better at it than i was
you could do it faster and two it also
got me used to managing somebody on a
small scale before being fully
responsible for them
before i was their entire income and had
to learn how to be a good boss a good
leader a good manager good mentor good
coach
i could i could play
on a smaller scale and develop the
skills
and so i think people wait too long
because they feel like they have to have
a giant budget you could hire somebody
for one hour a day
you know instead of buying
starbucks
you know i don't know how much this cost
five bucks four bucks whatever
right instead of buying starbucks every
day
you get two coffees that's
eight to ten bucks
you hire somebody for ten bucks an hour
to do that thing for you
one hour a day that frees up your time
to go do other things
so i want you to start being
more resourceful to try to find
other ways through instead of thinking
i'm by myself i'm all alone i can't do
it
there's a famous expression that goes if
you want to go fast
go alone
if you want to go far
go together
you have to build a team
your mission is too big your purpose is
too big
to make your dream happen
you have to focus in on your micro
jordan level ability and to spend more
time doing it
to stop spending time on the things that
don't produce value and that you don't
have a lot of interest in
and to start thinking about how can the
people around me support me better and
if they're not going to support me how
do i find people who will
because your purpose is too important
you haven't even come close
i've tried everything you haven't even
come close to trying everything how many
things have you tried
there's a million things you can do you
have not even come close and don't use
that as a beat yourself down that's a
push forward to say there's a million
more ideas inside me there's a million
more ideas inside me that i can use to
accomplish this goal there is always a
way remind yourself make it your mantra
put it on a t-shirt there is always a
way
and you are going to find it
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch comparing yourself to
others is actually fantastic and here's
why check out the video next to me i
think you can enjoy continue to believe
i will see you there that's kicking
yourself down what you need to do
you flip it and say wow that person has
done so much that's what's possible